hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update Ubisoft Toronto head Jade
Raymond has expressed some frustration
that some games treat gamers like idiots
in response to an interview from the
grid asking her what video game tropes
make her cringe Raymond said I don't
like the assumption that all people who
play games want big chain saws and women
in bikinis not all gamers are teenage
boys and even teenage boys want more
than that the interviewer said that
protagonists of many popular video games
are often husky voiced emotionless
[ __ ] and Raymond seemed to agree she
said it's got to change right pointing
out that even traditional action movies
have evolved to a point where their main
characters are more narrative ly complex
she did mention Grand Theft Auto is
doing a good job of using interesting
characters like the new immigrant
underdog but Raymond isn't satisfied she
said there still isn't a game where you
get to play an old lady that's my dream
so what are your thoughts on jade's
remarks why don't you leave a comment
below and for even more game news check
out gamespot com